Me,
the worst measure,
since I work as a nurse,
it's, uh,
the me that's going to be questioned,
see the me completely removed,
state or apartment medical assistance
where we are on the territory,
we have the right to be treated,
to be treated,
so it's uh.
For everyone,
even if we have no papers.
The immigration law has not yet passed
precisely on the me,
but it will godeux-mille-vingt-quatre.
As a result, they will
remove the me and replace it with something,
the management will be
only on vital emergencies,
people are going to arrive in super serious states.
We are in France anyway indeux-mille-vingt-quatre
and we get to the point where,
in fact,
if this law passes,
I don't know if this state and this
society still deserves my skills.
For me,
the most scandalous measure of this law,
is the delay in the payment of family allowances,
of APL,
the impact on family
parents for example
who are separated from their children for years
and can't get them to come
and it will be even more difficult.
And for me,
it's really 1 headlong rush to
the project of the extreme right.
I think the worst measure in this law,
is to degrade the access of foreigners to
certain social benefits.
First, because
it will impoverish thousands of families
and in particular
in the of Créteil
there are a lot of single women with it.
Children who will meet again uh.
Far below the poverty line
immediately because of this reform.
, it's going to start,
uh.
of our students in poverty.
So, for me,
the worst measure,
it would really be the loss of the right of the ground.
It is quite unfair to estimate that
someone who was born in France
and foreign parents
does not have the right to acquire nationality
of the country in which he was born.
I think it's a step back
because France
what is meant to be the host country in
country of human rights.
And there,
this law,
it goes against all that
well, France used to be.